good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy
Wednesday it is hump day here at the
dough State Jack's Hatter I'm doing good
and full candid nature like we always
are we're so transparent and authentic
Claudia and I have been recording and
then my computer froze and force
restarted so this is take two on
Wednesday July 12th the good news is we
were maybe 15 through the episode yeah I
mean we lost 20 minutes which is a big
chunk it's not like you know three four
five minutes it was 20 minutes yeah like
we covered a lot you know okay let's
tell everyone what we covered okay I
told everyone
um
this idea that I'm working on for
Jackie's maternity leave I can't get
into all this again okay oh
like this idea that I'm having just like
kind of you know making installments for
when Jackie's out maybe doing you know
Taylor Tuesdays hubby hump days you know
Ben coming in on Wednesdays it's an idea
we're working through Jackie and Alex
spitballed back and forth we didn't come
up with anything concrete we basically
just came to the conclusion that it's a
work in progress and that we need to
schedule a separate brainstorm to
continue the brainstorm but do let me
know what you guys think about that
unless you don't like it then I don't
want to hear but she loves installments
so keep that in mind that if you have
any negative to say like you're kind of
coming for turdy's jugular you're kind
of like chipping away at what makes me
me right but yeah tell her how you feel
then we dove into uh the Shania Twain
concert that I attended last night
um overall good show you know love me
Shania she looked great she sounded
great her personality I'm not you know
entirely familiar with and I was shocked
to learn she's a little quirky you know
a little bit of an oddball you didn't
know that she was a little quirky
like no I watched her documentary and it
was kind of serious
um you know she talked about her divorce
and Lyme's disease so it was it was more
and her upbringing so you know I could
tell she had a personality but it wasn't
like you know Shania appealed back yeah
but like where was she recently where
she was wearing that red wig
yeah she's been like running around town
in wigs and she's you know I understand
that sometimes you put a wig on and it
changes your whole personality so maybe
that's what she's going through yeah but
it's also just like a quirky thing to do
interesting note from the show was that
she did not um do a costume change until
the Encore which I thought was
interesting especially because between
songs she had these like elaborate you
know dancer while she was off stage it
was like dancers and like you know
hyping it up and then she came out in
the same outfit which I thought was
interesting I personally kind of like
that because I mean one she needs breaks
so she could do whatever she wants with
her brakes maybe have a snack have a
beverage go to the bathroom
um but sometimes it's just all about the
music yeah obviously it's not era's tour
maybe you're kind of like accustomed now
you've been spoiled when we all walked
into the arena we all had been to era's
tour and we all were like damn this
place feels so small and it was Madison
Square Garden we were like we were just
like coming like the last concert I'd
been to was the Aeros tour and I went to
three so like to scale it was just kind
of um it was just it was just shocking
it was a small intimate show I felt like
I could see everyone in the arena that
is really funny we were all like does it
feels so small in here that's really
funny and messes were Garden seats like
20 000 people it was not small you're
spoiled for Life literally
Taylor spoiled you and then I was
telling you know everyone oh my God we
talked so much okay then I was telling
everyone about this couple who was
standing in front of me who was so this
was worth repeating okay so she came out
to play um You're Still the One
and actually you know she did this whole
speech before where she was like I'm
gonna bring someone out to sing this
with me and you know I've known this
person for a really long time we've
never sang together and we were so
excited me and Margo were like who the
hell is it going to be because Shania is
like really A-list and she's a lot of
like famous friends when we saw her at
Stagecoach she brought out Nick Jonas
like she's weirdly friends with a lot of
singers so me and Margo were pretty much
set on it being Harry Styles because
they are close
um and turns out it was not Harry Styles
she said please after like hyping it up
so much she's like please welcome to the
stage Hoda
and it was just kind of like a
collective pause because Hoda is a queen
would take a bullet for Hoda but she's
not a singer she's a talker no and to
sing on the song that you all came there
to hear right it's just not what you
came to hear
yeah so we were all like question mark
and it turns out Hoda uh said I'm
actually you know here to present you
with it was like the 20th anniversary of
shania's like Dave not debut but like
the album that blew up that has you know
all the songs on it I think it's called
come on over
um just hit like the 20th anniversary
and it hit you know 20 million copies
whatever so they gave her this plaque it
was a nice little thing and I was like
okay bye Hoda and then I was like hold
up but I still want you to sing with me
and I was like I don't feel like that's
necessary but apparently Shania I
thought it was
um so they did sing like a little chorus
acoustically and then Hoda left and
Shaniah sing the whole song by herself
which like was what we all can't what we
all came for and for those of us who
don't know the song How does it go
oh you're just kind of you're obviously
like you're trying to make me not mad
that we had to not record I'm better I'm
bettering you're bettering me up all
right it goes a little something like
this you still don't wanna run to the
one that I belong to You're Still The
One I kiss
goodnight that song always makes me
think of Jackson Brittany from Venom
pump rolls because that was I went to
their wedding and that was their first
dance song and actually like I loved it
that's so beautiful I don't have any
associations with it um so we need my
Association maybe I'll take yours on an
association by proxy yeah or this next
story that you're gonna tell will now be
an association maybe you could even send
me what you have yeah so in front of us
there was the cutest older couple who
were just like being cute the whole time
and then when she's saying you know
still the one they were grasping onto
each other for dear life hysterically
crying the man like could not stop
wiping his eyes we all behind them were
crying and we took like all these cute
pictures and videos of them because like
I just felt like it was a moment they
might want to you know relive show the
grandkids and a few minutes later once
they had like stopped crying and
everything and she moved on to a more
upbeat song I tapped the lady and I we
were all like nobody wanted to tap her
and like ask for her phone number
because we were like either this is cute
or like incredibly weird of us we
weren't sure so of course nobody would
do it so I was like um hello and I was
like I took some you know really cute
pictures and videos of you and your
husband during that song do you want me
to send them to you she was like oh my
god of course and she gave me her phone
number and then she texted me afterwards
she was like thank you so much and it
all ended up good but I after doing it I
was like that could have gone either way
yeah though if I were on the receiving
end of that I would love if someone like
was capturing me candidly being cute and
then I didn't yeah but like it's a
private moment you know you're not
thinking about other people looking at
you sure it's a private moment but
you're in a stadium or in a yes Arena
Arena so like how private is it and okay
at worst like she doesn't want the
videos or she has them she doesn't care
for them and everyone moves on like I
think it's worth it
I was telling you like if you really
want to go viral on Tick Tock like you
should post the video and be like we
were at the Shania concert sitting
behind this sweet couple when they
played this song like I don't know how
people on Tick Tock yeah yeah conjure
emotion
well and then I was telling you that I
obviously you know that thought did
cross my mind to exploit these two
people's you know genuine moment for
content and perhaps clout
um however it felt wrong it felt
exploitive it felt like you know these
people didn't ask me to take photos of
them and like I I'm not the type of
person who approves of taking pictures
of people without their consent I've
done that in the past and I've learned
my lesson and then I was telling you how
while I do agree with you and ultimately
come to the same decision like you
actually might be standing in their way
of like being viral Superstars getting
free Shania tickets for life like Shania
performing at their vow renewal like
sometimes you kind of have to take a
chance and and exploit the elderly
sometimes you do have to take a chance
and exploit the elderly but then what I
was telling you
was that you know oh that is a
possibility but also the video could
like flop and then you know I just like
exploited these people's tender moment
and I've decided to not take the risk of
maybe getting Shania Twain tickets or
maybe exporting this tender moment
Between Two Lovers and I was telling you
how I decided not to and I was telling
you how I understand
great which I do understand but I do
want to see the video still I'll let you
know if it's worth
it's yeah like it's it's you know some
things are okay to be left unposted
that's something I'm learning in my
later years oh that's true that's that's
a lesson that's the damn truth that's a
lesson you gotta learn the hard way um
and I've learned it
and you know I don't need to post
everything I think and everything I take
I just I think that's okay oh for sure
um yeah
yeah
so then you were telling us that you
know you have a really big day today
which is why we decided to podcast from
home to just kind of mitigate any you
know potential physical strains yes so
we've been going back and forth all
weekend if we were going to do studio
today
um because we both have a big day
actually like don't minimize your day no
idea is not that big it's more about you
like let it be about you Drex it's so
hard for me oh God so um I'm doing talk
shop live tonight at 7 p.m eastern time
the link is in my stories um it's gonna
be so fun it's a live stream with the
girly swirlies I'm gonna be selling uh
signed copies of my books available for
pre-order and we're just gonna be having
like a girly time I'll be taking
questions from the live chat it's gonna
have like a little bit of freaking Fred
energy well I had told you in our
previous recording that I felt like the
TSL tonight was going to be giving
freaking Fred energy that's what I had
said you had said you did say that and
is that what they call it TSL
oh I just made that up I don't know I
like it
uh uh because I like it so that's this
evening I want to make sure that I have
enough energy and physical wherewithal
to do that so we decided to not go into
the studio today and we are podcasting
from home you know what's another thing
I'm learning in my later years
conservation is key whether that be you
know conserving your physical energy
conserving your social battery
conservation is a real thing for sure
you could even like zoom out conserving
the rainforest
such an important task conserving
other things that need conserving
no the thing is and I feel like I just
said this conservation is good I feel
like you said that I'm not entirely sure
but I feel like I did yeah no now it's a
good it's good it's a good word
conservation no the I think probably the
last thing I was telling you in our
previous recording that I wanted to
bring up not everything we said on the
First Recording needs to be brought up
it wasn't like that amazing yeah no
sometimes we lose like half the episode
and we're like you guys
we would have won a Peabody if that
yeah and it maybe was too good for this
world for this world it's like the Tower
of Babel and like God just like knocked
us down to size right this wasn't that
but we did talk about a lot of things
right we just like covered a lot of
ground which was annoying but like it's
not content I was necessarily like super
proud of we weren't gonna submit like
that episode to the Shorties or the web
to the Streamys yes totally or the
potties
but I think it's important because
something yesterday I made a mental note
to myself I'm like gotta thank Jax
for what she's done for me because
yesterday after we wrapped the toast I
went to do Joey camastis podcast which
is a Barstool Sports podcast where I
went to the bar stool offices
and when I was done I walked out of the
studio and Joey was like before you
leave there's like a bunch of people
toasters in the office who want to meet
you I'm like fabulous and I'm basically
walking around and meeting all these
people and everyone was like Teddy and
it kind of set in for me in that moment
that I have achieved a childhood dream
of mine which is to have like a nickname
that has caught on you know I tried to
give myself nicknames I told the story
when gbt was on the podcast a few weeks
ago about how just like as a child like
I craved having a nickname there were
certain kids in the class whose you know
last names were being abbreviated or
just had these nicknames and made them
special and I so desperately wanted that
and I never had it and you have given me
the gift of uniqueness and specialness
because everyone
and I don't know if I've ever properly
thanked you for that so that's what I'm
doing here now well you're so welcome
you're so deserving of a nickname
because there are so many things about
you that are just worth
nicknaming and you're so and there's so
many things about me that are unique
yeah and you're so familiar and everyone
wants to like feel
that kinship to you but you know calling
you by your given name what do they call
it your Christian name yeah my birth
name it doesn't it doesn't slap the way
that it I feel it should yeah so now
Claudia is very formal
yeah I'm so grateful I'm you know
indebted to you eternally do you prefer
turdy or turdy Lou
honestly
well as long as people are talking to me
I'm happy but if I had to have a
preference choosy Turtle
like the double the double the middle
name like makes it even more special you
know yeah and then your last name Turtle
Lou murder
yeah turdyloo ashrae Murda suffer
right Theo's mother so I just wanted to
put it out there that like I cannot be
called turdy enough I'm living my dreams
and if you had told like seventh seventh
grade me that you will grow up to have
like an internationally recognized
nickname because you know the toast is
huge in Canada I don't know if I would
have believed you it would it really is
a dream come true
that's and what if we told you in
seventh grade that's in the name was 30.
do you think you would have been like
and they're calling you like in The
Recess like turd
so yeah I don't know if the nickname
would have slapped as hard in middle
school because kids can be vicious right
however everything hurts the name is
kind of Taken on its own meaning that
like I don't think people are even
putting together that like you know
there's the word poop in my nickname you
know I agree
it's it's Larger than Life now it's
honestly larger than me maybe maybe
that's your next tour
right the turn it a little jaggy the
tordy Lou the Tour de Lou
that's the one that's it yeah and that
joke wasn't on the previous podcast
so now I feel like is there anything we
talked about in that previous 20 minutes
that we lost that we haven't covered
here
just if you wanted to share the factoid
that you knew that you were able to
stump Margo with that Shania Twain is
not honestly I by the way when we were
talking about the Shania show I was like
trying to remember everything I spoke
about in the previous recording and I
intentionally skipped that fun fact like
who cares okay but Shania Twain is
Canadian if you ever want to throw that
around and she lives in Switzerland if
you like just what I brought it up I
guess now we'll talk about it is you
know she's like the queen of country in
countries like so Americana and like you
know all that but she's a Canadian queen
and I know of course you can have
country music in Canada I believe
there's a big you know Community crew
over there
um but it's just funny like I just
thought it was interesting so I was
sharing my Shania fun facts with the
group at the concert last night because
I'd recently watched documentary which I
do highly recommend
great thank you
I feel caught up so yeah is that
everything that we spoke about yeah I
just sounded like Amanda Bynes and she's
the man but what did you say there
it absorbs right up yeah yeah
when she puts the tampon up I feel
caught up
it absorbs right up
I don't know if that's a movie I will
truly ever stop quoting why would you
like why would you have to why would you
have to who would make you no one would
make me but you know sometimes you like
naturally stop referencing things it
fades yeah like I hope like honestly the
way I feel about She's the man is the
way I feel about being called turdyloo
like I hope nobody ever stops but like
things happen naturally yeah but not
that
not that bad like because I see you for
what you really are which is which is
ugly yeah right so now without further
Ado we've got a great show five stories
dared hosters
and it's time for the fast five stories
that you do need to know
and the fast five stories that you do
need to know are brought to you by
Branch Basics the branch Basics premium
starter kit will provide you everything
you need to replace all of your toxic
cleaning products in your house it's
really a no-brainer so Branch Basics
products are non-toxic they're
hypoallergenic free of fragrance hormone
disruptors and harmful preservatives
they're baby and pet safe and they're
clean and cost effective so you know
we've got the choice Bros running around
we've got Harry running around touching
every surface possible it's so important
that we are taking care of our homes in
a clean non-toxic hypoallergenic baby
and pet safe type of way and that's
where Branch basic has entered the chat
I love the branch Basics dishwashing
pods they are so easy to use they get my
my you know smelly dishes all clean the
Surface Cleaner is great and I feel like
Jackie is obsessed with Branch Basics
every time I come to her house she's
like hey did you try my new soap like
she's always kind of like talking about
Branch Basics no and I'm like you're
kind of you're kind of toxic about your
non-toxic cleaning products it can be
toxic to be so high on non-toxicity and
yeah you always come over like for lunch
so the table gets little messy I'm like
don't worry about it my all-purpose
cleaning so true watch this and Harry's
right there he's watching too and also
Harry like loves to clean so it's fun to
be able to give him cleaning supplies
that he can actually play with and
without the worry
so you could save 15 off and get free
shipping on your starter kit when you
use code toast at branchbasics.com again
that is code toast for 15 off plus free
shipping when you purchase a starter kit
Branch Basics
b-r-a-n-c-h Basics
b-a-s-i-c-s.com code toast for 15 off
and free shipping today's episode is
also brought to you by game time buying
tickets to your favorite events should
not be stressful game time is the fast
and easy way to buy tickets for all the
sports music comedy and theater near you
with killer deals on last minute tickets
and their best price guarantee you can
stop stressing over tickets and get
hyped for all the fun that you're gonna
have so game time is the place for last
minute ticket deals forget planning
months in advance game time has deals on
tickets right up to the day of the event
get exclusive Flash Deals on tickets for
football basketball baseball
concerts comedy the theater and more if
you'd like to check out the spring
musical make sure you're getting game
time tickets on the game time app
here's what's so great about game time
and why they're the fastest growing
ticket app in the country get images of
your seat before you buy you know
exactly what you can expect when you
arrive you can buy tickets in a matter
of seconds it's literally two Taps and
you're set and tickets are sent directly
to your phone so you never have to dig
through your email snag the tickets
without the stress with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account and use code totes for twenty
dollars off your first purchase
that's uh game time app
g-a-m-e-t-i-m-e terms apply so just
create an account redeem your code toast
for twenty dollars off download game
time today last minute ticket deals
lowest price get guaranteed and it's
also just great like to have on your
phone all the time like if you're
traveling you're going on a bachelorette
party or you just find yourself in a
different city it's a great way to find
out like about the cool happenings in
the town that you happen to be in and
then you're like the cool fun friend who
always just has a great ideas and little
do you know the secret is game time
that's so true
that's like the friend I want to be yeah
that's a good hack
life hack
y oh okay our first story which makes us
officially caught up to where we were
because we were just going over the
first story which is that Britney Spears
reveals her bombshell Memoirs title
topless cover and release date so
yesterday Brittany and her team revealed
that her Memoir is called the woman in
me and it will be hitting bookshelves on
October 24th the cover features a black
and white photo of a topless Britney
taken in 2001. the lyric is from her
song I'm not a girl not yet a woman and
it will be published by an imprint of
Simon and Schuster
I'm just trying to find a woman in me
that song means so much to me if you've
seen my comedy special you know like why
that song literally raised me yeah and
it
it just was so pertinent to that time in
your life when and actually actually I
would say you were a girl at the time I
know you felt confused but objectively
you were a girl not yet a woman no
certainly not but I think that song was
a part of my journey to Womanhood 100 I
do I think for a lot of girlies our age
like that song played in left an
indelible Mark yeah
it's on our souls so it makes sense that
that would be a lyric she references and
at first I didn't get the title I didn't
realize it was from that song I thought
it was from a different song that's not
by her but I like it uh because I like
it yeah I mean I'll probably read this
book I do like celebrity Memoirs um
I feel like
this is literally what I was saying as
we got cut off last time so let me
finish my thought now okay so I find
myself thinking a lot about Britney's
finances like of course she's like you
know a huge pop star she has tons of
hits she did tons of tourists she did a
Las Vegas residency you feel like that
money will never run out but of course
like the conservatorship was meant to
preserve that money but I think it ended
up taking a lot of money out of her
pocket there were so many people like on
salary and just like literally living
off the conservatorship
um she also like really hasn't worked in
many many years I think the the one
thing she's done is that song with Elton
John which was of course big but
streaming you know doesn't make you a
ton of money it just is a platform for
you to then tour and sell merch and do
all that stuff so I feel like Britney's
finances like aren't really
um I don't think there's like this
endless well of money for her
um given all those circumstances that I
just
talked through and so I felt like this
book you know the she got what 15
million right oh I I wasn't sure but I
feel like you know the book is
definitely like a a money thing as
opposed to like and I think it's also
like a wanting to tell your story type
of thing but I feel like it's definitely
um
something she needs to do financially so
I don't know what that means in terms of
like what the book is going to provide
for us got it so yes it was 15 million
which is one of like the biggest deals
what I was saying when we got cut off
which was that I'm kind of
um
unsure about how I feel about the book
whether I'm going to read it whether I
feel like it's like necessary or the
right time because I feel like she's
still healing from everything and I feel
like a book is something that you write
more it's like a retrospective of
everything that's happened and it's
clear from you know everything that she
puts over that she's just like living in
the moment enjoying her freedom and like
not fully
past everything that's happened so I be
very curious like what this book has in
store for us and like where the story
sorts of sort of ends and like where she
is now mentally I will wait to see like
what the reviews are if you read it
first and you're like you have to read
it
um yeah and same with like The Toasters
like I'm just gonna see what the what
the buzz is because I do feel like a
little skeptical that it's a little
premature
and not she's not at like the end of
this chapter
no and also I mean I feel like the kind
of elephant in the room is like when you
you keep up with Brittany on social you
I don't think you know a word you would
use to describe like her state of mind
is like Lucid it feels like she's
definitely like still suffering a lot of
the consequences of like being put on
medication that she wasn't supposed to
be on and like really being so like
manipulated so it seems like it's still
a person in crisis not someone who's at
the end of the journey and can now look
back and see see it for what it was
right she said when she like announced
the book she was talking about it
yesterday she said I worked my ass off
and had therapy to write my Memoir and
now when I think about like the way that
this book must have actually like
physically been written I feel like it
was like her and a therapist and a
Ghostwriter in a room and like the
writer just like writing down all of
these things and and putting it together
for her yeah like
I I think that would probably be a good
method yeah
yeah I guess if you want to get the
story out of her yes
so I don't know I there's so much like
in my opinion like mystery still when it
comes to Brittany it's like not entirely
sure what's going on so just like most
things I think we'll have to wait and
see for what this book holds yeah and
this book like could answer some of
those questions like of the mystery of
her yeah I am living for like the very
threatening nature of her promotional
content thus far I worked my ass off in
therapy so you guys better like it but
if you don't that's okay yeah she said
okay guys so my book is coming out very
very soon I worked my ass off for this
book I had a lot of therapy to get this
book done so you guys better like it and
if you don't like it that's fine too
yeah it's like talk a big game but if
you don't like it that's fine too that's
literally like both sides of my
personality like you better like it but
if you don't that's fine yeah
we'll just have to wait and see I don't
like I think he's with Brittany I feel
like the culture
has like made me care about like her
journey when like I'm not even I'm not
like a huge Britney like I'm rooting for
her so you know wholeheartedly because
I'm a human being but I feel like if it
weren't for all the documentaries and
the movements free Brittany like I might
not have taken up such an interest in
this story I felt like it was kind of
thrust upon the culture
um
so I like want to read it just to like
be a person who keeps up with culture
but I don't have this like you know
natural desire like it's just not
something I'm particularly and is it bad
to say like particularly interested in
yeah no I agree with you but that's also
funny considering like she was such a
big part of our child I know she was
like our girl and when you think about
like Jessica Simpson's book like we
loved Brittany more than we love Jessica
aside from her being your birthday buddy
and like how much that book once you
actually read it like how much you took
away from it so there is ample
opportunity for this to be just like
that because I I do want to say I do
want to say I don't think I liked Bernie
more than I liked Jessica oh okay that's
what I wanted I like I believe so I
believe you snitch loved Britney you
love Jessica and also she was your
birthday buddy I liked them both I think
I liked Brittany more than Jessica
personally and when Jessica Simpson's
like Memoir was coming out like it took
a lot of teasers for me to be like oh
this is something that I want to read
and then it like totally changed my life
and then it took for me you reading the
book and telling me 45 times to read it
to get me to read it right so I wonder
if I'll have that same experience with
Britney's book I do not know I think the
potential is definitely there but the
way that I feel is like everything we've
learned about her through like the free
Britney movement and the documentaries
is like this girl has been through so
much leave her alone and I feel like her
now needing to write a book about
everything that she's been through just
feels more like you know milking of the
Britney cow
yeah but I understand what you need that
what you're saying which is that she
needs money I think she does but I think
she can't tour but the other thing that
she has working in her favor is that
like based on what we're see like I
think she has a relatively low cost of
living I don't think so an a-lister
well for an a-lister yes but she
literally um is always on vacation she's
like always taking pictures on her
private chats like I think every time
she like she doesn't leave her house and
when she does she goes on vacation and I
think it's a quarter of a million dollar
vacation just like between the planes
the Villas like I think and I think
that's what she just wants to be doing
she was in a prison for so many years I
completely relate to that but I'm just
like so like fixed on on the money of it
all like I just don't think there's a
lot of money left
yeah
which is crazy because at a point in
time she was the biggest star in the
world yeah yeah and she just she was
being like um forced to do this
residency for literally like years and
years yeah
but when there's so many people like
eating out of your ass it runs out right
so I could understand why she like took
a huge book deal was like listen to my
therapy write what you want there's the
book which is why as a reader I'm like I
don't know that it's a book I'm gonna be
like desperate to read I think she's
also Limited in what she can do for
money like she can't tour I don't really
think like I'm sure you know
all the big interview shows offered her
a ton of money to sit down for like a
documentary or an interview
um I don't know if she's in the right
head space for that so I think she's
really limited into like a book where
you can have it completely edited have
people help you is really one of her
only options
yeah
she could like do more endorsements
she could
um yeah she could
she could sell merch I feel like people
would support her merch honestly I think
so too she also has so many affordable
things that she says like skinny as a
needle like yeah and like I feel like
people just want to support her and
they'll buy the book for that reason so
honestly Britney needs merch and she's
always like dancing and like taking
videos like just wear your merch in your
living room yeah free idea we need we
need a line of Brittany merch
are you ready for our next story yes
which is so interesting okay Adrian
Bailon reveals that Solange Knowles was
originally cast in Cheetah Girls
wow so Adrian Bailon was on a podcast
and she stunned fans when she revealed
that Solange was actually supposed to be
in the movie she said I got the role and
at the time I was told that the other
girls were chose who were chosen were
Raven Simone as Galleria Sabrina Bryan
as Dorinda myself is Chanel and Solange
as Aqua wait I'm sorry I don't think I
ever put together that the character's
name in Cheetah Girls is Dorinda
yeah I actually think that that that's a
typo like no honestly it feels right no
I feel like if I ever thought about it
Doria or something no I think maybe they
called her like four it's Dorinda wait
I'm shocked by that information like
that's literally an older woman's name
like that's so weird especially because
I really feel like Galleria Chanel like
they kind of nailed the names yeah
during this definitely an outlier and
she's the girl who like
yeah yeah yeah
so then she uh Adrian had said that
aqua's character is supposed to be from
Houston and um
accent and everything and so while it
was supposed to be Salon she said and
originally she was supposed to be Aqua
Kiely Williams took over the role when
Solange ended up not doing the film at
the last minute for whatever reason
that's so funny I could literally see
the role of Aqua being written for
Solange Knowles like it actually makes
so much sense it makes so much sense
like when people heard this they were
like oh my God we were deprived of this
movie which would have been amazing I
mean Keely Williams was amazing and like
I don't she was I don't think of Cheetah
Girls and be like something was lacking
missing but I feel like Solange would
have been amazing and even though now
you know it would seem off brand for her
I actually don't think that it would
like I think she could have still been
who she is now while having sex with the
girls
I actually think it would have been an
amazing role for her and I think they
got a great replacement because like you
know when you think Solange you
obviously think Beyonce girl group
Destiny's Child and 3lw was like similar
to Destiny's Child
honestly they did a really good job of
replacing Solange but I do think the
role initially being Force launch is
also an inspired idea yeah I agree and
it's just like I'm shocked I you know
what's so just like something I want to
say I don't know why I need to like
preface it
um
I just love Adrian Bailon like I love
her connection to the Kardashians I love
how much she still loves them and they
still love her even though like I think
her relationship with Rob like was
really traumatic and ended very poorly
um I just love her and I feel like every
time I talk about her it's in a positive
way and I just love her and I don't want
to hear anything bad about her ever I
agree she's like a positive force in the
industry she is I feel like she's
probably like a really nice person and I
think she just gets like a lot of
opportunities and roles because she's
like a pleasure to work with yeah and
she's good at her job and she seems
professional and she's there to work and
she's on your Newsroom right now right
is she yeah when the she was on the real
for a very long time that show got
canceled and now she's one of the main
e-news hosts so it's her Kelty and
Justin I believe so nice I like that for
her I'm just like I'm I wish her well
like every now and then I'll check in on
her Instagram and I'll just send
Positive Vibes her way I'm like you go
Adrian
you send them virtual like do you type
something or you no no no no no you
don't I'm just sending love and positive
vibes no I just like in the I put out
positive thoughts for her in the
universe and I hope that they find their
way to her and it looks like they are
because I know she's really happily
married she's killing it in her career
like I just love her yeah agreed and
this is a fun fact that she shared with
us when she didn't have to and that love
I have for her like stems from her being
like a comfort a comforting force in my
life as a child Cheetah Girls was my
favorite movie and you know
honestly Solange missed out she really
did still on she's lost I agree
Solange's loss was Kelly's game
yeah she was great she was great yeah
she was great
are you ready for our next story yeah a
little more Taylor Swift arrows ticket
drama Ticketmaster postpones tailors
era's tour sales in France Taylor
Swift's French fans were in a frenzy
after Ticketmaster suddenly halted sales
for her upcoming shows in Paris and lion
and then postponed to a later date on
Tuesday Ticketmaster shared that the
sales had been put on hold and they
added that all codes not already used
would remain valid and it would keep
fans posted for a new on sale time as
soon as possible
why is it so hard for Ticketmaster to
literally do the thing they were created
for why is it so hard for Ticketmaster
to master selling tickets
they should not call themselves
Ticketmaster they should call themselves
ticket loser like they literally it's
the Ticketmaster thing is so problematic
because like there are no other
platforms you can use to sell tickets to
these venues because like Ticketmaster
is owned by Live Nation Live Nation owns
all the venues it's like this it's
really a monopoly and like you can't use
one without the other so it's like
somebody could build a competitor that
sells tickets that can do it in a way
that's not moronic but they wouldn't be
able to do it because Live Nation owns
all these venues like it's really it's
um incestuous
so it's like all these artists are
at the whim of Ticketmaster like just do
your job
did you see me up this podcast
no because it's my job yeah except for
the 20 minutes before but yeah yeah no
just move on
um I agree and it's like if they want to
have a monopoly it wouldn't bother me so
much if things were working really well
like I feel like and I feel like they're
also really trying not to get like
filibustered or whatever like censured
in Congress and it's like well if you
just gave the people tickets and you
did what you're supposed to do
like we wouldn't have such complaints to
be calling our local Congress people
yeah and of course like the Taylor Swift
thing blows it up and makes it you know
such a big story because you know it's
the biggest tour literally of all time
but even with um like just normal shows
that have normal demand like there's
always problems whether it's
like you know first of all their fees
are so insane it literally is Criminal
doubles the price of your ticket there's
just like these regular issues that are
beyond the Taylor Swift thing even
before that like it's just not a
pleasant experience but we're all like
being forced yeah plus like scalpers
ion pick it I'm a touring artist myself
I experience many issues with
Ticketmaster there's literally no other
option like you can't not use
Ticketmaster yeah
and it sucks for the artist it sucks for
the fans like it just sucks figure it
out
I don't know but the French fans are not
happy also I had seen like a lot of the
Europeans fans were like we got our
codes like it's gonna be great like they
were like kind of bragging that there
was so
seamless put together
and it's not so you know it's not
sorry to the French
yeah no just we come did you see
speaking of the French the new trailer
for Napoleon
no Joaquin Phoenix is playing Napoleon
in a big epic about Napoleon for the
theaters for a streamer for the oh I
think the theaters it didn't actually it
was an apple I think it's Apple TV plus
now that I'm thinking about what I saw I
mean the theaters are having a moment
you know I know that's actually our next
story is it our next story that's
brought to you by Legacy box oh my God
yes the theaters are having a moment
thanks to Legacy box as you know where
you're
do you know where your old box of old
home movies is have you checked that box
in a while to make sure it's not hot wet
molding all of that old media can break
down over time if it's not preserved and
it'll be lost forever so you think you
just got a box of old stuff you're like
I'll get to it later but you know what
you might not have a later because the
elements are coming for your vhs's and
your cassettes and Legacy box is here to
help Legacy box is easy it is a way to
preserve your old memories get them
digitized and brought into the modern
era you basically load up your legacy
box with all your old tapes films
pictures and send it to them you'll get
it back on a thumb drive or a cloud
ready to watch easy to share it is so
simple it's basically like magic so they
can do VHS tapes they can do camcorder
tapes they can do pictures their team
will professionally digitize everything
by hand it's all done right here in the
USA and you'll get it back on a thumb
drive or the cloud along with all of
your Originals we did it it was
literally the most magical thing like to
get all these memories back back that
you never thought you'd see again we had
in our basement just like literal boxes
filled with old we grew up in the BH as
era and to get it all back we all sat
around watched like our old performances
of us you know at piano recitals and
performing in our living room it was
really such a gift I can't recommend
Legacy box enough don't let the summer
heat age your video tapes your film
reels and fade your photos visit
legacybox.com toast to shop their nine
dollar tape sale it's legacybox.com
toast you can unlock this incredible
offer do not miss it it is a great gift
for someone in your life or just do it
for yourself today's episode also
brought to you by Caraway Caraway
cookware is non-toxic and chemical free
so you can fill your summer with your
favorite recipes without worry Caraway
makes cookware with the convenience of
non-stick without the concerns of toxic
forever chemicals so you get the best of
both worlds you can have stunning
cookware that is cute and it is gorgeous
and it is also effective it is non-stick
but it doesn't have any toxic chemicals
you don't have to worry about all these
Freaky Deaky chemicals seeping into your
food and getting into your family's
bellies don't miss Caraway Summers
refresh event from June 20th to July
15th it is almost over for a limited
time get 10 off site-wide on the
internet's favorite kitchenware it's the
perfect time to take care of all your
summer gifting ideal for both graduates
and newlyweds with cookware bakeware
food storage and tea kettles to choose
from there's something for everyone
their internet famous kitchenware is a
staple for any home it comes in various
modern Shades to fit with any design
aesthetic caraway's non-stick chemical
free ceramic coating makes it easy
cooking and easy cleanup the 9 toxic
kitchenware means that food can be
prepared with peace of mind that know
hard to pronounce chemical will leach
into your healthy ingredients all the
sets come equipped with complementary
easy access storage solutions to keep
the kitchen tidy you know I love to make
a chili in their Dutch oven Ben loves to
make eggs in their frying pan it's
perfect for all picky eaters it's
perfect for any kitchen you can get any
color that'll match your aesthetic visit
carawayhome.com toast10 to get 10 off
during their summer refresh event it is
almost over the sale ends July 15th so
make sure you don't you go to
carawayhome.com toast10 or use code
toast 10 at checkout certain exclusions
apply Caraway non-toxic cookware made
Modern thank you Claudia I'm just loving
all this non-toxicity promotion tonight
welcome it's so important
our next story getting back circling
back to what we were saying the movies
are having a moment and the star of
Oppenheimer whose first name I'm going
to attempt to pronounce correctly
Chilean Murphy says kill Killian I think
and not psyllium
I'm not sure Killian Murphy says he's
100 going to see Barbie in the theater
amid the Oppenheimer same day opening so
there are two big movies of the summer
right now and the star of one is
supporting the stars of another
Killian Murphy isn't letting a little
competition put him off seeing the new
Barbie film the actor said he is 100
going to see Barbie which will be
battling it out against Oppenheimer over
opening weekend later this month and he
thinks it's great that the movies are
being released on the same day he said
I'll be going to see Barbie 100 I can't
wait to see it I think it's just great
for the industry and for audiences that
we have two amazing films by amazing
filmmakers coming out on the same day
yeah you can spend the whole day in the
cinema what's better than that
I mean it's so interesting how like
theater culture has changed because I
feel like in the Heyday of like big
movie Blockbuster weekends like no stars
of a film would even be allowed to ask
be asked questions about the competing
film coming out that weekend but my God
people are so desperate to like get
people into theaters that they're all
like one big happy family now and it's
funny because like the two movies could
not be more different so like really
there is no competition like I think
maybe you might be the only person who's
like so interested in Oppenheimer and
like World War II or whatever it's about
and Barbie like there's not a ton of
crossover yeah but it's cute I mean you
would think like there's two big movies
over the summer them being released on
the same day would be a bad thing but I
think it's just like building up hype
for the movie industry a lot of people
are there so many like funny memes about
like Barbie versus Oppenheimer I do
personally they're calling it
barberheimer or whatever I want to see
both I actually so I heard a little bit
about what Oppenheimer is about I'm
pretty sure it's about like the atomic
bomb
yeah
um and this man Oppenheimer like living
with
you know the consequences of having made
it
um yeah I'm actually uh going to the
premiere so because you know fun fact
Josh Peck is in Oppenheimer when's the
premiere did it not Premiere yet
no or the New York Premiere the way that
these premieres have me in a tizzy like
Barbie Premiere was a few days ago
wasn't it like three months ago it keeps
premiering I don't know I don't
understand how like the junkets work no
the Barbie press tour has been going on
for one whole year now and I guess it
ends on July 21st
um when people can actually see the
movie so that's exciting yeah I
personally even though I understand what
Chilean is saying about spending the
whole day at the theater like having
done a double header once like it was
not for me and with these two movies
being so different and also probably
like a lot to process especially if you
see Oppenheimer first
I don't think I would see them on the
same day no offense me neither if I had
to I would see Barbie first okay
um
and then go into Oppenheimer I think
that's probably the better way of doing
it
um and you would do that on the same day
I'm saying if you know gun to my head I
had to do a double header I think the
right way to do it is to see Barbie
first or like you see Barbie first like
maybe we have lunch and we could talk
about Barbie like and what we thought
really rehash it
that way our our we are tabular asses
when we see Oppenheimer and then we can
go home after and like sit with
Oppenheimer it feels like a film that
needs to be sat with yeah but it's crazy
that it has so much buzz like I know
everyone's like because it's Christopher
Nolan like right I don't know her
first time I've ever heard of him and
then I was watching a teaser or
something so they were like it's
Christopher Nolan director of this that
this that and the ones that stuck out to
me because I had heard of them were or
seen them as a gladiator
okay the Martian which I just saw yeah
which was good
and what else
there was other stuff hold on
Interstellar
Inception oh Dunkirk which you saw
not my favorite just like a lot of stuff
he's just a famed director oh and that's
why I was talking about Napoleon because
that is Ridley Scott wait hold on
another famous I'm sorry Ridley Scott
was the one who who did Gladiator and
the Martian
so the are you talking about not
even the Martian
we're not really like filming I'm just
like I think it's safe to say my head is
gonna explode no I think if you're like
into filmmaking and like the art of you
know the cinema you obviously know
Christopher Nolan and his work I'm much
more of like
um like I like films you know made by
like Tina Fey and Kayla Mindy Kayla so
we're just different like that you know
yes okay so when I was seeing that
teaser thing was when I was watching
Napoleon I just need to clear this yes
Ridley Scott he did the Gladiator and
the Martian and now I'm also seeing
House of Gucci Black Hawk Down oh I did
see Black Hawk Down that was a good
movie
um and the other guys say he's a
respected filmmaker the other guy does
other stuff
okay well happy for everyone you know
it's been a rough year well not year
years for the theater industry
um and it's having a moment especially
also you know Mission Impossible I think
comes out this week oh yeah Tom Cruise
was like you know doing a ton of
interviews all about the theater he's
he's trying to like make Mission
Impossible like up there with
Oppenheimer and
um Barbie it's not up there because it's
not on the same week and I don't you
know it'll be good but it's like Top Gun
is like you know his thing no Mission
Impossible is his thing but also I
didn't even know they had a new movie
coming out except that I saw Sophia with
enough at the premiere yeah like Mission
Impossible kind of got like sidelined
because like nobody cared because it
wasn't a part of like barberheimer right
um
I'm so curious to see how these movies
actually perform because me too there
has never been more hype for a movie
ever than Barbie like there's never been
more marketing every brand has a collab
with Barbie everyone was at the prince
and Jackie we're still 10 days away from
the movie actually coming out no I know
like I don't think there's ever been
more marketing dollars and brains behind
a movie I need to know how much money it
makes
yeah and I saw you know we were talking
about how Mattel obviously owns Barbie
and then they're doing that Barney movie
we were talking about and I saw I forgot
where I saw this but do you know that
they have 17 more projects in the works
Mattel for like you know products that
they have being made into movies I
believe there's a Polly Pocket movie I'm
a little frightened by that
yeah it just feels like
Overkill Overkill yeah yeah
so also there's another movie at the box
office that everyone's talking about the
sound of freedom
oh I landed I landed on uh sound of
Freedom Tick Tock people are really
upset about it it's a disturbing movie
it's about child sex trafficking yeah
and it's like totally
um like upsetting because obviously
child sex trafficking is like an
upsetting thing and then people are um
saying that like they're turning off the
air conditioning in all of the theaters
where they're playing sound of freedom
because they don't want people like the
elites who like are involved in in child
sex trafficking don't want you to see
the film like the film was really hard
to get made and like no streaming
services would take it on and then I was
on by the way it's like getting so crazy
on Tick Tock then I was like you know I
follow I think like Netflix on Tick Tock
and they premiered like a new movie and
people in the comments were like why
didn't you pick up sound of Freedom like
there is a war going on on social media
about this film I've heard the film was
like really disturbing and of course
like it's such an important message but
like I really don't know if I have the
capacity to like digest that honestly
yeah also it's not getting a lot of
press and it didn't make I think it's
already made like 40 million dollars
which in today's movie
um right metrics is like huge and you
know then the media doesn't talk about
it and then it's like it kind of plays
into well it's like you know you're
you're silencing someone blowing the
horn on sex trafficking because you're a
bunch of sex traffickers no and then I
also saw on social media like some of
the media is painting it as like an
alt-right film which honestly I don't
know if they should say that because it
makes the alt-right look pretty good
like oh then they care about child sex
trafficking right so I just feel like
everyone is handling this whole sound of
Freedom thing like really poorly because
like the more I see people talking about
it I'm like oh these people on Tick Tock
maybe they're not so crazy yeah yeah I I
was looking on um variety because I
wanted to see how much it made so that I
have a frame of reference when
Barbie and Oppenheimer come out and like
all the headlines were like faith-based
movie faith-based movie oh faith-based
because I guess
the the tagline is like all of God's
children are worth saving or something
like that
it's a nice message yeah so I agree I
don't think I have the stomach for it
but
it's really taken the country by storm
and it's based on a true story it's
about a man who's like devoted his life
to ending child sex trafficking I saw
Mel Gibson was you know involved which
was confusing I think the director or
the star was in Passion of the Christ
um that is also a very very
controversial film I remember
do you remember like I never saw The
Passion of the Christ I don't even know
what it's about but like I remember when
I was a kid like everyone was talking
about it and like people were like
picketing like theaters that was such a
crazy time that was a crazy time I don't
remember what was controversial about it
but I feel like me neither they had like
Jesus like on a cross being killed
oh and why is that controversial I don't
know like not controversial but it's
like
disturbing I don't I don't know we were
literally five I couldn't say that was
such but like the way I remember that
time in my life like just remember the
time I'm like if you ever think like
what's Claudia thinking about she's
thinking about the time that The Passion
of the Christ had the universe in a
chokehold
yeah I'm trying to see what the
controversy was
despite criticisms that Gibson
deliberately added material to the
historical accounts of first century
Judea some Scholars defend the film as
not being primarily concerned with
historical accuracy I guess it was
historically inaccurate
and I'm that was like before Mel
Gibson's like obsession with
anti-Semitism correct yeah The Passion
of the Christ was considered by some to
be too graphic and violent as it shows
the whipping nailing to the cross and
piercing crown of thorns
I feel like it was just Passion of the
crime maybe it was just before it's time
because now they put anything in movies
right like I've seen I can't imagine
what was so disturbing about it that we
haven't seen on like Game of Thrones it
says these intense bloody images cause
distress to many viewers who experience
sickness or uncontrollable tears
so they had to actually edit the movie
with less violence
after the initial run
some kids can hang
and there's also he was accused for
anti-Semitism for his harsh depiction of
Jews in the movie oh and oh so maybe
that was the start of his journey with
anti-Semitism yeah
that's beautiful damn not The Passion of
the Christ on a hump day
no I'd like the way you just opened up a
recess of my mind when you said The
Passion of the Christ like that was such
a crazy time and so I don't know if Mel
Gibson is involved with sound of Freedom
any more than the fact that he's
associated with passion of the cry Sky I
do not know right no no that's that is a
good connection
oh uh are you ready for our fifth and
final story which again like if your
stomach was in knots just keep it there
because
um our fifth and final story is
disturbing yet Justified okay
Larry yep I love this story I
know me too sicko Sports Dr Larry Nasser
was stabbed in his cell away from prison
cameras so Larry Nasser was attacked in
prison inside of his cell and out of
sight of cameras according to an Insider
the child molester who sexually abused
hundreds of gymnasts including leading
Olympians during his time as the U.S
Olympic gymnastic doctor was stabbed at
least 10 times with a makeshift
makeshift weapon inside his federal
prison in Florida on Sunday but it is
deemed an unwitnessed event because it
was inside a cell the main blind spot
for cameras inside the high security
lockup oh shucks
Shucks
surveillance cameras otherwise scan
corridors in common areas although it
was not immediately clear if they caught
the attacker entering the cell the
stabbing was the second time that the
pedophile has been attacked since
getting sentenced to hundreds of years
in prison in three different trials for
molesting young athletes and possession
child porn
like one of the things probably the only
thing I love dearly about our prison
system is the hierarchy
um and the way they like these are you
know people most people in there have
like committed horrible crimes but the
way they have like a zero tolerance
policy for like people who with
kids like is my favorite thing
um and I just love love love that this
man was stabbed ten times and to that I
say do it again you know yeah no it was
I think everyone saw that headline and
was like
good go get him I didn't realize this
was the second time he was stabbed me
neither I wonder if it's people like in
prison who one like have obviously beef
with what he did or beef with him or if
it's like people on the outside parents
who are like yeah get them
well I mean have you seen what he looks
like he doesn't you know appear to be
the type of guy who's gonna you know
um
really do well in prison he's like this
disgusting looking nerd who weighs like
a hundred pounds soaking wet so
I imagine he's not the most popular and
then you know he's famous too so like it
gets around like that's the guy who you
know with kids yeah and I imagine
it's a recipe for un disaster I can also
Imagine him like being the worst
as a person like in his personality like
he's he thinks he's like a big swinging
doctor and it's like do you remember a
pedophile yeah and like you assaulted
like the
the gems of our nation yeah like our
crowning our crowns 100 of them yeah and
you think you're better than us because
you're a quote-unquote doctor get the
out of here no and like I just I
sleep well knowing that like pedophiles
who get caught like have like being in
prison is is one of the worst experience
it's horrible but nobody has a worse
time in prison than pedophiles because
they are like the lowest of the low and
I just that brings me peace yeah as does
you know I guess no cameras caught it I
hate it right it's so it's just too bad
you know Shucks shucks
um so those were good stories Jax yeah
they were I enjoyed them immensely I did
too
and the show's not over which I also
enjoy immensely because Wednesday is our
dear toasters day so we do an advice
segment every Wednesday where we get
three submissions from different curlies
going through different things and today
is no different if you ever want to
write in we have two ways of submission
you can go to the toastpodcast.com
scroll down there's a little submission
box it's totally Anonymous or you can
email us dear toasters gmail.com now
today we have two submissions and one
update we have an update from the girly
last week who kind of shook the toast
Universe um with her submission about
her legs and her bug bites oh my God I'm
so glad to get an update so quickly a
quick turnaround she I respect that
because you know sometimes we we help
girlies we give really well thought out
advice and we never hear from them again
which is fine you know because I have to
assume that like you took our advice it
went so well you literally forgot to
write us because you're having such a
fabulous time you're on vacation too
having said that it still hurts and if
we've helped you in recent months please
write us an update
now deer toasters is brought to you by
rakitin so rakitin is the most rewarding
way to Shop and Save because rakitin
members earn cashback on everything that
they buy rakitin is a shopping platform
that partners with over 4 200 stores
across every shopping category so that's
Beauty that's clothing that's
Electronics Home department stores pets
Etc so you're already shopping at your
favorite stores why not save while doing
it it's a no-brainer so some of the
stores that work with rakitin are
Sephora you know which a lot of us are
shopping at Daily Macy's Ulta Nike
Adidas Petco eBay Zappos Expedia that's
a good one Best Buy
so if you've used rakitin you know that
the experience is fabulous it's really
fun it's really easy and there's really
no reason not to use rakitin it is the
smartest way to save money when you shop
you can get cash back at over 4 200
stores across every single category
there are so many brands on there that
we all use every single day so there's
no reason not to get started on racketon
the membership is free and it's easy to
sign up so start shopping at rakitin.com
or get the racketon app to start saving
today your cashback really really adds
up racketin is spelled
r-a-k-u-t-e-n.com they also have an app
racketon spelled the exact same way your
cashback really adds up it's something
that's so easy to do
and it's fabulous so there's really no
reason not when you're shopping at
Macy's Adidas Walmart whatever it is
just make sure you got the racket in set
up get make a membership it's free to
sign up and you know you'll be saving
money and you'll be better than all your
friends who are not so ready for deer
toasters ready okay hey Jackson turdy
Lou love you guys so much I've been
seeing this guy for two months and he's
a total Peach on but I've recently
discovered that he's an all-natural type
of man so he makes his own soap body
wash toothpaste deodorant he doesn't
even believe in shampoo and he uses aloe
and beef fat as Skin Care even as
cleaning supplies are made of like
vinegar and alcohol me I need my
products and that includes soap so I
bring them slash buy them when I come
over to his place but it's really
causing friction in our relationship is
there a compromise here or is this a
deal breaker oh that's interesting I
would say off the bat my thoughts are
like he can do him as long as like you
can do you and and he's not like trying
to get you to stop using Pro products I
mean eventually when you guys like if
you move in together it will come to a
head like what kind of cleaning products
you're gonna buy honestly I think Branch
Basics would be a really good compromise
because yeah it's so true
um but I think as long as he's not
trying to change you
then you don't need to try and change
him and as long as he doesn't smell and
all this well that and the be fat
working for him that's what I wanted to
talk about like she didn't write this
but I need to know in order to really
help like what does this man smell like
is all of this like effectively keeping
him clean or does he have like Bo and
yellow teeth like because that for me is
just like a deal breaker like you smell
I'm out like and I respect
people who are principled in terms of
like you know toxicity and like wanting
to you know make their own shampoo or
whatever
um having said that I do feel like
people like that
and someone like me like we're so
different like there's no way like that
type of relationship could even work do
you know what I mean I do know what you
mean I feel the same way but like one I
think men and women have different needs
so like maybe that would work for a man
but like I I need shiny hair you know
like it's just yeah it's not gonna work
for me so I feel like I feel like I
don't care what product Zach uses I
don't notice what he uses so like if you
were making his but you don't notice
because he don't smell right no so I'm
just saying like as long as it's not
actually like affecting you what he's
doing I I don't see why you guys can't
like be parallel in what kind of
products you use again it will present
to be a challenge at certain points in
your relationship but I think if your
relationship is strong enough you can
get through it and also like not saying
either one of you has to change but
maybe one of you becomes interested in
the other one's way of doing things and
it doesn't mean you switch to all be fat
and great like products but like oh you
know what I could make my own
I don't know
body wash or something small things to
be honest
to be honest and I'm just speaking like
If This Were me like this would be a
deal breaker for me
I just I have to be honest I'm not
saying I would give it a chance
personally I would be okay I wouldn't
and only because like let's say he
doesn't even smell okay like I am just
so
different from this person like there's
no way this relationship could work like
I I think it would be a waste of my time
honestly
Okay and like toothpaste I'm sorry
toothpaste what if he has a good
alternative
I'm sorry I'm just not buying like I see
people like on reels and stuff making
their own moisturizer and it looks nice
they've used coconut oil
a couple yeah
okay people on real make their own
moisturizer with like the exact same
ingredients that like this guy's like
being alternative yeah okay if you want
to make your own moisturizer and
literally use shea butter coconut oil
like all the things fine but like be fat
like I'm sorry no aloe vera is not
shampoo
I'm just saying like I understand if you
want to be open towards it I don't know
where it's gonna lead you
but you know it's hard to find a nice
guy and so if you guys know I'm sorry
work no like we are not compromising
like hygiene for love I'm sorry we said
he doesn't we're going under the premise
that he doesn't smell that like it's all
working for him I I'm sorry I I actually
can't get under that premise it seems so
highly unlikely you're gonna have to
clarify if he smells
yeah for real
because that's a deal breaker yeah
okay so you have two different
perspectives yeah run
all right
dear Jackson Clerk and The Strife Bros
I need some advice on how to update my
wardrobe and gain confidence with what I
wear I'm 29 fashion obsessed but I
suffer majorly from feeling
uncomfortable in my body I was raised
not being allowed to paint my nails show
any skin never worn makeup not even for
my wedding but I desperately want to
change that I don't know where to start
or how to grow my confidence and stop
wearing hoodies and biker shorts XOXO a
bare nailed fashion tote disaster if
it's helpful my favorite fashion icons
right now Paige de Sorbo Sophia Richie
turdy Lou
wow wow well that's actually what I was
going to say I would say
um this is a place where like
influencers can actually be really
helpful and especially influencers who
do this for a living like who have you
know daily like to know it updates with
like shopping options not just
influencers who post their outfit that's
like inspirational which is always good
to have inspiration but I would say like
find an influencer who has a similar
body type to you or like has a style
that you like as well but also I would
say size wise and proportion wise it's
not just about like weight it's also
about like you know how does she have a
long torso do you have a long tour so
sure are you busty are you right exactly
like do you want to accentuate your
waist does she accentuate her waist I
would find some influencers that you can
relate to their um body type and their
and their fashion style and then like
troll their links
yeah also I would just get comfortable
with the fact that like this is going to
be a transitional period for you and
like you're going to take risks and you
might look a little nuts and like that's
okay like you have to like do it wrong
before you can figure out like what you
like and what looks best on you so like
just honestly like throw caution to the
wind and just go balls to the wall
because you really won't figure out like
what you like until you try everything
oh my my Approach is a little more
methodical like I would say like dive
into the into the materials that you
have available like do some research
find the people explore Instagram like
really there's so much out there that
you can
clean inspiration from like people's
like to know it's you know uh so many
influencers like literally this is their
job as like posting outfits then posting
like dupe outfits and just go through
everything see what you like see who you
relate to on their body type and I think
it'll be easier for you to nail down
like out of all those things what you
like best and then you know eventually
you could take the training wheels off
and shop for yourself
copy and paste to start yeah no totally
first of all like those platforms like
ltk Pinterest like it's really
um that's what these things are designed
for like there's so many resources out
there for you but I just feel like you
know what like this is gonna be a big
change like just lean in
yeah when it comes to like your makeup
and your nails like try stuff you know
I'm wearing purple nails right now
because I'm like it's temporary if I
don't like it I'll get another manicure
in a week and it will just have been fun
like you got to try some stuff for fun
but I also understand not wanting to buy
a ton of stuff that's like not gonna
work for you and you're gonna look like
a clown like it's an expensive Endeavor
so I think doing as much research as you
can beforehand
will help you but I think this is so
exciting yeah I love this charity for
you yeah godspeed girly send pics when
you're updated you know yeah
all right our third and final is an
update from the girl last week who said
um her husband recently told her that he
found all the mosquito bites on her legs
really unattractive and she let us know
that that was unbelievably hurtful
um she spends you know all the days
outside with the kids it's summertime
she's just being like a devoted mother
and her husband basically said it was
like unattractive and you know he was
having a hard time having sex with her
because of her mosquito bites
and we basically ripped him into an
and
um and she wrote she wrote us an update
and we said that she should do the same
yeah so she said hi mosquito girl update
I volunteered my husband to go camping
in the backyard with our kids when he
came back he got bit he was covered in
mosquito bites and I told him that it
was gross and unattractive we laughed
about it and now Everything feels even I
love that sometimes the best advice and
I for an eye
yeah no because you know what while the
whole world may be blind if I'm blind
everybody should be 100 it only that
feels right a bite for a bite I love
that for you way to get creative and
sometimes the only way to make someone
like see themselves is to put them
exactly in the position that they put
you in you have to walk a mile in their
shoes and I absolutely love that for you
good for you for taking control I hope
your husband felt like a prick and the
world
feels that he is justice has been served
thank you for writing us an update it's
so nice to hear from our you know
girlies all grown up and especially one
week later because I think that that's
the mission took a lot of people by
storm like a lot of people said
something to like people who I'm like
friends with are like oh my God I was
listening that to your toasters was
crazy and we were all talking about the
bug bites yeah it was a bug bite you
know heard around the world it's true so
I'm glad that we could put a lid on be
of service
well that's our show thank you to
everyone who wrote into Deer toasters
again if you ever want to submit it's
totally Anonymous and it's deertoesters
gmail.com or just head over to
thetosepodcast.com and there's a
submission box at the bottom of the home
page we love you tomorrow's episode uh
tpd up in the air we'll see what's going
on you know TBD we'll see how TSL goes
on the TV
or remote
thank you guys so much for listening to
the testimony Morning Show where we
deliver the fast five stories you need
to know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere
podcasting be found so at Spotify iTunes
sister public radio everybody castbox
all the places
I love you bye